texas border county officials struggling
to contain a surge of migrants now
declaring the crisis at the border as a
quote-unquote invasion
that move could force the biden
administration to act or set the table
to let states deport migrants on their
own and a new study from the u.n has
labeled a border crossing between the
u.s and mexico as the deadliest
migration land route in the world
but despite all the negative headlines
the department of homeland security
chief thinks things are going well
i think that we are
doing a good job we need to do better we
are focused on doing more and we are
doing it with our partners to the side
caitlyn as you listen to that what would
if you were advising him and you've
advised the president what what should
the policy be put aside i mean the the
optics they seem to the to fumble every
once in a while but what should the plan
be the three or four things you would be
advising this uh homeland security chief
to do title 42 needs to come back uh
there is still an ongoing health
emergency and you can use that remain in
mexico should be in place apply for
asylum but do it for mexico if you look
at the numbers that have been expelled
with these two policies they're
significant it would change the course
of what's happening at the border and
that study you cited about the deadliest
path for immigration being mexico to the
united states
the author of that study said the
numbers increased in 2021 significantly
more than any year prior roughly doubled
what happened in 2021 the unraveling of
the very policies i decided to you get
the border under control you do it maybe
it'll help you with the midterms
jesse
well
i mean this is like jimmy carter saying
he's doing a good job with the hostage
crisis
this is insane um i don't know they've
shattered the record of border crossings
i don't if do they understand what a
good job means unless the point is to
bring as many people as possible
illegally into this country then yes
they're doing a very good job if it's
the deadliest land crossing in the
entire world why would you encourage
hundreds of thousands of people to make
that journey that's like saying hey
come to my castle
and my castle's surrounded with the
deadly mode of crocodiles but if you get
through the deadly mode of crocodiles
i'll give you free health care and free
college tuition you'd never do that i
mean to make a great reality tv show but
you would never do that to someone else
that you cared about obviously doesn't
care about these people they also said
that they're fleeing my orcas or
whatever his name is
they'd be they're fleeing climate change
and covid now when we send reporters to
interview the border crossers at the
border and they say why are you here
have you ever heard a border crosser
saying it's hot in el salvador no or i'm
i'm fleeing covet 19 no they say joe
biden they say president biden asylum
they say those things so that's just a
total lie i said this before you got to
put the factories from china put them in
northern mexico that will keep the
migrants there happy and employed and
not surging north for jobs last thing if
dana were here i'd make fun of her and
say did you read the new york times
article about
salazar the ambassador to mexico it was
a leak campaign by the biden white house
trashing their own ambassador for not
working well enough with the mexicans
now this is joe biden who's
tailored his whole career on being this
great diplomat he's rallying this big
unified
uh
collabo over in europe but he can't even
get along with our southern neighbor how
hard is that he's our neighbor you
should just be like hey mexico let's go
have a drink let's straighten this out
i want to have a drink theme uh um greg
would you would you think that this is
something that the what that they should
be doing differently would you would you
echo the things we've heard i'm going to
take a different tack today i think this
is a mess and it's a dishonest mess we
need to overhaul the process that's for
sure but i don't think at this point
after doing our b block and playing off
of what jesse said we should be
dissuading good decent people from
coming here true it may be just for a
paycheck but that's often just the start
we are talking about largely god-fearing
family-centric people who aren't afraid
of a day's hard work they are in short
the complete and utter opposite of
what's dripping out of our campuses like
coagulated pimple juice
i don't even know where that came from
but i go back to the b block right
all of those people bash the united
states all those blue checkers all those
celebrities i would be willing to bet
all of them were born here
uh and i would take a million people
from somewhere else who want to be here
over 10 000 people that don't when the
judge said why don't those people go
back talk she wasn't talking about
immigrants she was talking about
hollywood celebrities and i'm with her i
mean
honestly
would a guy or a girl from guatemala
burn an american flag when they come
here no they're happy to be here would a
young hispanic couple be okay with drag
queens in kindergarten hell no right
they're bible fearing they'd be going
this is not appropriate would a nigerian
mom and dad join in on a riot in the
name of social justice because they just
moved here and they opened a business i
don't think so these are eisenhower
republicans and old school democrats i
say bring them in
trade them for the worthless white
workstars that are destroying this
country that's my replacement theory
yeah but you don't want to have them
jump over deadly crocodiles no you don't
i'm totally anti-deadly crocodiles good
jesse
that is mr gutfeld's opening argument
judge
the only person who's destroying this
country is joe biden
joe biden has made a decision that he
wants
two million four million six million
illegal immigrants to enter this country
and the problem is if you remember three
years ago if we said there was a surge
at the border we were racist well now it
is a damn invasion all right and it's an
invasion that the united nations of all
people says is the deadliest trip on
earth all right the problem is not just
what's happening to them on the way here
the problem is what is going on once
they get here the people who are coming
here and you know what i'm not going to
say they're good better and different i
don't know who the hell they are i want
to know what their record is i want to
know who's a drug dealer i want to know
who's a pedophile i want to know who's a
drunk who wants to kill his wife i want
to know all this stuff and it's not
funny greg the truth is they are
destroying this this country who is
destroying this country let me finish
greg in terms of what's coming into this
country the fentanyl that's coming in
that you know what the united states is
not controlling the border the cartels
are controlling the border and the
cartels are selling their fentanyl to
the mexican the china is selling
fentanyl to the mexican cartels they're
bringing in people they have arteries
all through this country and whether or
not you like immigrants or don't is not
the question the question before us is
why we are allowing a generation between
the ages of 18 and 45 to be killed by a
drug war and an undeclared war by china
toward the united states where mexico is
making a fortune that's the problem we
will we will come back to this topic but
ahead president biden is beefing with
jeff bezos and big oil after getting
called out on his latest spin on spend
on surging gas prices hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now